I was checking out the David Pakman show subreddit
this morning@davidpakman.com slash R E D D
I T and saw some interesting posts a bunch
of people have been picking up on this and
user Gilda. Rick asks, does Trump watch the
David Pakman show? And again is pointing to
this tweet from Trump from Tuesday night during
the New Hampshire primary were Trump tweeted,
boot edge edge is doing pretty well tonight,
giving crazy Bernie a run for his money and
many people pointing out that I have been
pronouncing Pete's name boot edge edge for
a while, but a lot of this came from Pete
or I remember early on when, uh, people weren't
sure how to pronounce Pete's last name.
He said, it's like the word boot followed
by the word edge twice. So I don't think this
is evidence Trump is watching the David Pakman
show, although I appreciate the sentiment.
I was sort of joking about that. Brody Mulligan
posted a new lo Jimmy from Philly's call on
the live stream last night. Yeah. Jimmy from
Philly called in and it was, he's a furious,
uh, Trump supporter who, um, has actually
been, been separated from his daughter for
alleged physical violence. It's a horrible,
horrible story. And Brody wrote berating homos,
mocking Pete's candidacy as nothing more than
a person with supporters voting for him based
only on his sexual orientation, topped off
with needless cruelty towards the transgender
community stating what's next. A transsexual
for president David hung up on him eventually
and apologize to the callers and viewers about
having to listen to all of that. Um, uh, and
then Brody finishing by saying, I wish Pacman
would stop taking his calls sometime.
Yeah. You know, it was a very ugly call from
Jimmy, from Philly, from Philly. And I did,
uh, I did end it prematurely, although arguably
not fast enough. Um, the, you know, when,
when called in and he was always loud and
rambunctious and uh, had an edge to him, but
we actually talked about, you know, his view,
why he likes Trump, his views on politics.
It was an interesting, I can't allow someone
to just get on the show and insult large swaths
of people with pejorative terms and all of
that. I didn't feel good about the call. And
if, if you know, that may be it for Jimmy
from Philly, if that's the way he's going
to do these calls. Lastly, Ethan at 18 posted
David the debate champion with a screenshot
from Saturday's Raj Royale. I didn't talk
about this on the show really, but I was on
a a game show on Saturday called Raj Royale,
which starts with 12 contestants.
Uh, after each topic is debated, someone is
voted off the Island, so to speak. And I did.
When I actually came out Victoria's, we're
going to publish the finale where I competed
against a gentleman going by the name airsoft
fatty. That's his name. I'm not, that's not
pejorative. Um, and we are going to publish
that to the YouTube channel over the weekend.
You can check out the full video on Raj with
two J's YouTube channel if you want to see
it. Uh, but a very, very enjoyable and a eye
opening experience. Join the discussion@davidpakman.com
slash Reddit